welcome back to CBS this morning we are
inside the beautiful Gilyard Center in
Charleston South Carolina just hours
from now the clock is ticking this will
be the scene of the next Democratic
presidential debate co-hosted by CBS
News with us now is my co-moderator for
tonight's debate CBS Evening News anchor
and managing editor that of course is
what's your name no I remember it well
and our colleagues who will join us for
the question tonight we got the a-team
they are 60 minutes correspondent Bill
Whitaker chief Washington correspondent
you are major Garrett Face the Nation
moderator and senior foreign affairs
correspondent that's Margaret Brennan
behind us as you can see seven lecterns
are all lined up there empty now but
tonight they will be the focus of the
political world and this room will be
packed these are the seven candidates
who will be swear to not swearing off
what I was trying to say squaring off
and the stakes could not be higher four
days from now voters cast their ballots
in the South Carolina primary with 54
delegates at stake there and one week
from today we have Super Tuesday with
listen to this more than 1300 delegates
up for grabs Bernie Sanders leads in
total delegates after winning in New
Hampshire and Nevada another strong
showing in South Carolina
followed by Super Tuesday wins could
make him extremely difficult to beat
they're already calling it guys a
Sanders surge nor let's begin there with
you because the latest CBS News poll
from us found that the majority voters
think President Trump will win a second
term so what do you think that says
about what voters are looking for
tonight well I think tonight the gloves
are going to come off this is the final
debate not only before South Carolina
but you outlined it Super Tuesday which
is the bonanza of Delegates for them
Sanders is the front-runner watch for
everybody whose name does not end with
Sanders take him on tonight last night
feeling the pressure Sanders for the
first time outlined just how much all of
his proposals cost which are between 50
and 60 trillion dollars and he just
released it last night yeah
and he attempted to release a way of how
he's going to pay for that with new
taxes with lawsuits with cuts to
military programs it's not clear yet
that the math adds up but it's more
specific than he has been in the past
knowing that this is going to be the
charge that you cannot win with a
Democratic Socialist at the top of the
ticket that's the charge that these
Democrats are going to make that's why
the CBS News poll reflects that right
now 65% of Americans think the President
Trump will win reelection you know so
we've been here since Friday and many of
the people Margaret have said they
haven't made up their mind 85 percent it
seems they're still waiting to see
what's going to happen at this debate
tonight we have Super Tuesday coming up
as well what when you think about that
what's at stake for all of the debt for
all of the candidates here that will
join us on stage for some of these
candidates survival for others momentum
Bernie Sanders in particular it's not
everybody's gonna make it after tonight
right that's right and particularly when
you look at some of the spending you
know I interviewed Joe Biden over the
weekend and he highlighted in this state
in particular which he has seen as his
firewall he doesn't like the word but
that is it the back stop to stop that
slide
he has been outspent and he has been out
staffed in South Carolina by billionaire
Tom Steyer he knows it's thinning out
some of his support here particularly
among african-american voters who he is
banking on to show up and solidify him
as the alternative the viable
alternative to Bernie Sanders so that's
what tonight they're going to try to
demonstrate as Nora laid out there will
be a target on Bernie Sanders back there
will also be one on Mike Bloomberg I
think it's worth spending a moment to
describe the dire situation for Vice
President Biden look at the percentage
difference in the first three contests
11 points and behind in Iowa from Bernie
Sanders then he was behind more than
that in New Hampshire 17 points and then
Nevada 26 points that is a deeply
negative trajectory it's not as if
Bernie Sanders and Joe Biden haven't
been squaring off they have been and
this is not the place the Biden campaign
wanted to find itself in South Carolina
this is as close to a desperate
situation for a vice president to be in
and firewall doesn't even begin to
describe how tough the situation is for
Vice President Biden
it is similarly difficult if your name
is Pete Budaj edge or Amy Klobuchar
because you've got to figure out a way
to differentiate yourself and make
yourself the central compelling
alternative to senator Sanders I started
off in the fall yes with he was an
overwhelming lead here and he's watched
that lead shrink and shrink and shrink
the voters here who were behind him in
the beginning have seen his lackluster
showing in the early caucuses and the
New Hampshire primary and they're you
know they're paying attention like
everybody else and Biden slowly has seen
his support here his black support here
drip away - exactly billing and this
will be the first primary where we see a
significant black electorate who are
turning out who say that they will be
turning out yet 60% which of course is a
majority how significant is the black
vote here tonight we are partnering with
the Congressional Black Caucus on this
debate the the black vote here is the
race as you were saying in in in general
in primaries across the country
Democratic primaries across the country
the black vote is about a quarter of the
electorate here it's 60% you cannot win
in South Carolina without winning the
black vote and as you reported Joe Biden
will have the endorsement of james
Clyburn the kingmaker in this state the
longest-serving and most popular African
American leader in the state we'll see
if that makes a difference for him but I
think what you're gonna see tonight
mm-hmm is an ideological fight for the
heart and soul of the Democratic Party
whether you want a Democratic Socialist
then you know senator Warren or someone
who is a Bloomberg more Wall Street
Democrat who in the past has been a
Republican and that's gonna be the fight
how much do we want to spend how many
social programs will the Democratic
Party provide and will they be paid for
by additional taxes whether I mean
that's this I think this is gonna be so
full of substance because there are
issues where many of the Democrats who
are running against Bernie Sanders have
said and my talking to their campaigns
they do not believe that his record has
been fully examined even though he's run
for president before against Hillary and
Bernie Sanders may have some explaining
to do with his latest comments where he
was talking about Fidel Castro and he's
doubled down on those comments as we go
into this debate tonight well he surely
double down on them then he he invoked
China to defend his comments and he's
gone to war with AIPAC the American
Israel Committee lobbying arm so he has
thrown a few bombs so to speak
politically that he will certainly be
pressed on tonight but in some ways what
I'm looking for here too is because our
it's such a critical moment these
candidates have to start presenting what
their vision is versus just saying I'm
running against the guy who's got the
job right now they've been running
against President Trump and saying I
will be better defining exactly what
that vision for what they're selling to
the American people is where we're gonna
start seeing them try to nudge out
crucial for Elizabeth Warren I mean this
is this is a big night for her she
started off sort of gangbusters but
again as was Biden she's had a
lackluster performance in these early
races and this is the place where she
has to pull herself out of the package
II for Elizabeth Warren is she built her
campaign steadily from April through
October and then what happened when she
started to get deeply specific on the
numbers of Medicare for all there was a
reappraisal we are now seeing Bernie
Sanders for the very first time starting
to get specific about his numbers will
that provoke the same kind of
reappraisal the damage Elizabeth Warren
also a week ago what was everyone
talking about we've barely mentioned him
tonight that shows you how rapidly
things turn around in politics one
bedroom a performance can make you an
almost also-ran he has got to have a
better debate to my performance tonight
to make a better first impression the
second time around
almost impossible in policy has been off
the campaign trail behind closed doors
preparing Franklin Berg for this very
they said that he will be ready there is
a lot to watch tonight and we will all
be there guiding you through Nora bill
major and Margaret we thank you
Nora and I as you know will moderate
tonight's Democratic presidential debate
co-hosted by CBS News Margaret matron
Bill will join us again this evening the
debate by the way is co-hosted by the
Congressional Black Caucus Institute the
Democratic National Committee you can
see that debate tonight at 8:00 Eastern
I love that it's an hour earlier 7:00
central right here on CBS and CBS n now
let's go back to Anthony and Tony in the
yes s morning focal get a little more
sleep Gail thank you